[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the marauders the death
eaters and peter pettigrew
aka worm tale now we know peter
pettigrew
aka wormtail as the defector of the
maraudus
a quartet of boys which consisted of
sirius black
remus lupin and james potter all four
boys began attending hogwarts in the
year 1971
and each of them were sorted into
gryffindor this was the initial basis of
their friendship
sirius black remus lupin and james
potter all seemed to have figured things
out while they were in school
at least to some degree but i'm not sure
that i can say the same for pettigrew
he was an insecure sniveling excuse for
a man
and though he was close friends with the
other marauders i don't think that they
ever truly considered him
to be their equal they were popular and
magically talented
and pettigrew was well pettigrew a young
and impressionable wizard
that lacked confidence and magical
mastery the marauders were hell-bent on
breaking the rules at the school
i'm a notorious for their rule breaking
and mischief making
the group existed for seven years from
to 1978 and all members were active
participants
in the first wizarding war all four boys
would also go on to join the order of
the phoenix which was a secret society
founded by dumbledore
that opposed lord voldemort peter was an
ally to the order of the phoenix
for some time along with the other
marauders that is
until he was made secret keeper for the
potter family
a secret keeper is a witch or wizard
designated to hide a secret
the secret is secured by the fidelius
charm which conceals the secret inside
of the secret keeper's soul
sirius black was the initial choice for
secret keeper but sirius
thinking that voldemort might target him
suggested they choose pettigrew instead
the following excerpt from sirius
addresses this lily and james only made
you secret keeper because i suggested it
i thought it was the perfect plan
voldemort would be sure to come after me
would never dream they'd use a weak
talentless thing like you
it must have been the finest moment of
your miserable life telling voldemort
you could hand him the potters
after being made secret keeper peter
pettigrew revealed his true colours
and in one famous act of cowardice and
disloyalty revealed the location of the
potter cottage to voldemort
he had been in correspondence with dark
lord already and this was his chance to
strike
to show voldemort that he was worthy it
was at this moment that the sniveling
disloyal man had secured his placement
as a death eater
a servant of the dark lord but for what
why would pettigrew leave the order and
his former schoolmates
to go and serve a darker purpose wasn't
he a
gryffindor the truth is that even though
petticrew was a member of the order of
the phoenix
and the member of the marauders he was
never truly accepted by either of these
groups
he was always pettigrew to them and was
frequently looked down upon
pettigrew was quite weak and mentally
impressionable and sirius
remus and james were all strong
characters i think that it's entirely
reasonable for me to say
that pettigrew's friends never truly
respected him
and viewed him as a little bit beneath
them despite being the good guys
after years and years of being dismissed
and not taken seriously
better crew simply hit a breaking point
a point at which he sought power
independent from those that he knew when
he turned to voldemort pettigrew saw an
opportunity to become his own man
voldemort probably saw that he was
decent in magic but also mentally weak
and he took advantage of that james
sirius and lupin were
ultimately good people but they were
also arrogant jerks in their youth
and pettigrew who was perpetually looked
down upon by them eventually made a
choice
as awful as it was to betray the people
that he previously surrounded himself
with
peter wanted power and his own identity
in some ways
peter's tale could easily be an allegory
for bullying and the bullied kid going
down the wrong path
though peter was in the order and one of
the good guys he was never really
appreciated by them
and he picked up on it when he saw
voldemort he saw an opportunity to
reinvent himself
and surround himself with a new group of
people the death eaters
becoming a death eater was totally
foreign to him but he knew that he
didn't like his present circumstances
and the prospect of joining a new group
a very different
but powerful people was inviting to
petticrew
who like to surround himself with people
in these positions of power
this is reflected in the following quote
from the prisoner of azkaban
when did i ever sneak around people who
were stronger and more powerful than
myself
but you peter i'll never understand why
i didn't see you with a spy from the
start
you always liked pick friends who'd look
after you didn't you
it used to be us me and remus and james
and it just so happens that when
pettigrew defected voldemort was the man
he was powerful and his victory seemed
imminent
pettigrew who was insecure and
vulnerable saw that he could be a part
of something powerful
and impressive and he made his choice
and that's it for this video what do you
think why did pettigrew defect and join
the death eaters
let us know down in the comment section
below until next time
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you